hey guys it's me again and let's solve
another leak code problem
merge two sorted lists so this is an
easy problem
it's a mainly fundamental problem
there's nothing crazy about it but it's
a pretty good problem to understand some
basic stuff so
we're given two linked lists right so
this is the first one
this is the second one both of them are
already sorted and we just want to merge
them
into an output linked list the only
catch
is that we have to use the original
nodes right like we can't create copies
of the nodes so let's say we have
list one and we have list two i'm just
going to take them exactly from the
example that they gave us
so we can actually focus on the general
algorithm itself
so your intuition will probably solve
this problem for you so
it's basically since the lists are
sorted we start at the beginning of both
of them right
now we can just compare the values so
they're both
one so it doesn't really matter which
one we pick
so we can just take uh i'll say list one
right so we'll take
this one and insert it in our output and
then move to the next one
and then just continue the algorithm the
only catch here is that right now our
output list
is empty right so this kind of gives us
an edge case because our we don't even
have a list itself yet so
what i like to do is just create like a
dummy node so
this is a pretty common technique and
you avoid
any edge cases you avoid the edge case
of the initial empty list
so let's say we start out with a list
right this is a dummy node it can have
any possible value so now we're going to
insert one
into our list now we're going to compare
two values
of two and one in this case the value
from list two is smaller so we're gonna
take it
insert it into our output list one now
we're gonna be comparing these two
so two and three the value from list one
is smaller
we take it and insert it into our output
two and then of course we can move to
the last value in list one so now we're
at
four and three which one of them is
smaller
of course three which is the value in
list
two i'm running out of space
but i think you get the idea at this
point so now we're at the two last
values from each list
we'll just take the value from list one
and add it
which is four they're both the same so
it doesn't matter now this is the last
edge case that we have to worry about so
now
for list one there aren't any more
values left right so we can't really
continue our algorithm lucky for us
there's only one value left in list two
but it's not
always going to be the case right maybe
there could be a bunch of other values
right four five six there could be other
values
in list 2. now what would we do in this
case well we can
do a really easy thing which is just
take the remaining
portion of the list so if we
run out so if one of the lists is empty
of course
the the list two in this case is still
sorted so we can literally just take
that list
insert it into the end of our result
right
so that's basically the idea okay now
let's write the code so remember
i like and most people like to use this
technique of creating a dummy node
so you don't have to worry about the
edge case of inserting into an empty
list
the tail of our list is initially
i'm just going to say you know the dummy
so
now we're going to keep going we're
going to iterate through these two lists
what's the condition that we're going to
do that basically
if both of them are non-empty right
because that's
when we can actually compare the two
values so while list one and
list two are non-null so now we can do
our comparison
so if the value of list one
is less than the value of list2
then of course we're going to take the
list1 value and insert it into
our tail so tail dot
next is going to be the node itself
right list one node
and then we can of course update our
list one pointer
now the else case is if list two
is less than or equal right so if they
were equal the else condition would
evaluate so we're going to do the exact
same thing except
list two is going to be inserted
and don't forget we do have to update
our tail pointer but the tail pointer is
going to be updated regardless of which
node we insert into our list so that's
why i'm not putting it in either of the
conditionals
and you might be tempted to just say
return
dummy.next return the list but
don't forget our condition was list one
and list two are non-null what if one of
them
is empty but the other one isn't right
now well in that case we want to find
the non-empty list
and then insert it at the end of our
result so if
l1 is not null then we'll say tail
dot next is equal to l1 so we're just
taking that remaining portion of l1
and inserting it into the end of the
list
else if l2 is non-null we would do the
exact same thing
with l2 uh only one of them can be
non-null so let me just run it to prove
to myself that it still works
and yep it does and some random
percentages that always seem to change
right now it's 65
but i'm sure if i submit it again it
could be 10 it could be 99
i don't know why leak code is so
inconsistent with this
but that's besides the point if this was
helpful please leave a like and
subscribe
and thank you for watching and feel free
to suggest any other problems that you
would like to see solved